[Music]
like to welcome everybody to tonight's
class on tactics as you know just
tactics are little three to eight move
sequences of moves where one side has an
advantage and they do a little
combination to win a piece or pawn a
knight for kit double attack something
like that I've been going through
combinations by a book by a Russian name
since NASCO borovsky it was written in
1936 it's a very good book though and he
has lots of nice examples and he has
themes every chapter has a different
theme so we did night Forks and things
like that tonight the theme is what's
called in chess the King chase where you
get an attack on the king but you've
routed him out from behind his pawns and
you chase him across the board and
corner him somewhere in the middle of
the board and checkmating now as an
introduction to this theme and you'll
see in when I bring up the notation
it'll have a heading it says stalemate
into checkmate
the first few examples are where the
king is basically in a stalemate
position and some of them will be will
be draws so if the king is can't move
that's obviously a draw but if the King
is merely obstructed in moving then the
kings in a very bad spot it means all he
can't really move anywhere all you got
to do is deliver a check then you can
get checkmate so that's why the topic is
stalemate in to checkmate but our first
two examples will be how if you're
defending and you know you've done this
in your own games where you you know you
have a bad position and you're likely to
lose maybe you're a pawn or two down and
you're desperate so one of the
fences if you happen to stumble on to it
if you can force a stalemate where you
still make your own King you get you can
get a draw and avoid what would
otherwise be a certain loss so that this
is a study this is not out of a game one
of the grandmasters put this study
together and in this position there is a
way to force a stalemate or to force the
pawn to Queen
so black with the Queen has an obvious
advantage white only has a knight and a
bishop and the bishop blocks our past
pawn
the only thing all the way you got a
couple things going for us the past pawn
the zone only needs to go one square
further to become a queen and then that
Queen would offset but blacks Queen but
we also have a problem see that black
pawn on f3 and the pawn is attacking the
square g2 next to our King which is
behind our H pawn and if the black King
gets out of the way black will threaten
Queen to g2 checkmate
so as we figure out what happens at a
certain point you have to guard against
that checkmate once that black King gets
out of the way of the black Queen so
there's a way to work with these
elements of the past pawn you can see
there's some checks with the knight and
the bishop the bishop can come back
sacrifice itself on f5 King takes but
then the black Queen threatens that
Queen the g2 checkmate
anyway rather than guess let's go into
it a couple moves because it's quite
complicated right here now who in the
audience so what happens if King takes
[ __ ] yeah pawn from pawn promotes with
check so it black doesn't get the
checkmate so he can't take the bishop so
he's got to move the King somewhere what
happens if he goes King to f6 now he
threatens the checkmate with the Queen
and he threatens to take our pawn what's
the drawing move for a white who sees a
good move for white here well first you
got how can you guard the checkmate
that's the number one thing yeah Knight
III notice that it does guard the
checkmate but it indirectly guards the
pawn because there's a knight fork if
the Queen takes the pawn we have a nice
little Knight fork of the King and Queen
now we threaten pawn up getting our
queen is there anything black can do to
prevent that I don't see any checks
anywhere no King moves for black do any
good no pawn moves do any good so I'm
gonna have to say that this this is good
for white gets out of his difficulty
it's not the stalemate of the main line
but this is sufficient because we are
able to force our pawn up to be a queen
and we'll have a queen
bishop and night against queen he can
win either the he can win the night
though but then we'd have a queen at
bishop but with his pawns he probably
may be a draw anyway let's go back now
let's look at the king to f7 well this
is easy or is it easy I was thinking it
was easy maybe it's not we should have
to guard the checkmate but the King
obstructs the Queen and black doesn't
threaten Queen takes pawn so I don't
think the King moves any good okay the
only other move is to go to the rook
file and notice that that this is the
main line but notice that's a horrible
position for the King he has no he's
almost stalemated himself he's in front
of the black pawn he's on the rook file
he can't move the King but at least he
does threaten the checkmate on g2 and he
threatens Queen takes pawn so it looks
like we stopped the checkmate with the
knight move which we're already saw but
we don't have the knight fork when he
does Queen takes pawn so let's see what
happens ok well if we were probably this
as the game we might give up and resign
here however but it's a study and we
know that it's a stalemate gives
encourages us to look a little further
ok any idea what the right move is for
whites
Knight to g4
did you see it said new variation when
it's the new variation that means I
didn't key it in and it's not the
solution but we need to look at it
anyway
so what's your idea how are you gonna
get a draw here oh you're threatening
mate Knight that's pretty strong I like
that but he can defend it pretty easily
by bringing the Queen over and then he
threatens Queen takes h4 pawn how do you
defend that yeah so even though that was
you did have a pretty checkmate we need
something a little more forcing than
that this is particularly hard but let
me point out that the black Queen has no
checks on our King at least immediately
okay I'm going to give us the next move
because it would probably be here all
night the knight moves up and attacks
the Queen that gains us a temple and
notice that the knight can check the
king with your Knight f6 check like you
said or he has f4 check so black has to
stop both those checks it looks like he
has to move his queen up to e5 to guard
both those black scores let's see what
he does that's what he does okay now
notice that the White King has no moves
the black Queen is on the black diagonal
so the White King can't go to g3 or h2
notice that the pawn takes away in the
g2 square White's own pawn blocks going
forward and the black King blocks the G
Foursquare now all you got to do is get
rid of the knight in Bishop and it's a
stalemate that's the idea what's the
correct sequence of moves I like Knight
to f4 check let's look at that now if it
says new variation it's the wrong move
if it if it accepts it it's the right
move
well I like that so I forces Queen takes
now what's the right move we got to get
rid of the bishop the only way we can't
go to g4 right g6 king takes all now the
pawn can move we got to get rid of the
stupid pawn how do we do that
yeah let's push that up
notice it's with check and notice that
the Queen still guards the h4 square our
King still can't move no matter what
black doesn't stalemate so that's our
drop drop by stalemate okay let's look
at another one of these things this next
one is another stalemate it's a draw so
in this this came out of a real chess
game the a white player was a
Grandmaster back in the eighteen maybe
the early 1900's late 1800s 1890s made
me a C's and whites in trouble see that
White's King can't move it has to
protect the pawn on e6 blocked by the
black King it looks like White's gonna
run out of moves he has some pawn moves
looks like black and running out of
moves that and if the King retreats the
e4 black wins by King takes c6 pawn
let's see how he found a draw let's go
through the moves
so it's White's turn in this position
would you move your pawns one square at
a time or two squares for your first
move one square you don't want to run
out of move so it's really quite simple
from that point of view so he moves that
one up and he could have moved the other
work pawn and blacks gonna do the same
thing because he wants to
last move with the pawn to force white
kingdom move back so he'll move one of
his pawn fry 1 square which he does
white does one more let's see what black
does ok he blocks it so now the black
has blocked the three pawns for white on
the Queen side so no more moves there
now we go over to the King side 1 square
1 square 1 square blocks it things are
really looking desperate now let's see
what white does in his desperation oh he
gives up a pawn and he can't move he got
his draw very clever we have one more
draw to look at now if you look at this
position you'll see that White has
probably missed played his game
somewhere along the line boy yes two
rooks and a queen white only has a night
that's pinned against his King and black
threatens Queen takes Knight checkmate
and White has a queen and White has up H
pawn and the Queen but notice that if it
weren't for the H bond which can either
move up or take the pawn and also notice
that if it weren't for the Queen if you
took the white H pawn and Queen off the
board it would be draw by stalemate
right all we got to do is get rid of the
Queen and the H pause and we get our
draw what's the right move for white
I would suggest that every move white
makes has to be a check yep that's the
only good check I see King over now what
do we do
let's go to g7 oh now the Kings within
our pawn what's the last move font up
check King moves and we got our
stalemate
I guess the l'amour will the story is
don't give up at least till you check
out your ear still mate possibilities
okay what now we're going into it all
the rest are wins for either black or
white so we're getting to the King Chase
part of the examples this is a tense
situation black is threatening Queen - G
- checkmate however black has some
weaknesses his King is in the corner and
the white rook can go to e8 check
forcing either the bishop or rook back
and we have a possible smothered mate
with Knight to c7 check Knight to a6
Queen - to b8 rook takes a knight to c7
checkmate so it's white to move and
obviously every move has to be a check
or black gets the checkmate so any
suggestions here yeah let's do that now
do you think black should interpose with
the bishop or the rook let's do the rook
oh he did the bishop let's do the rook
that's a new variation in this case
that's not going to save him because we
just do the night because the wreck no
longer guards king over double check
here
here here smother me yeah so white
weasels out in that variation rather
nicely so the only possible defense is
to retreat the bishop but it falls to
the same thing what's the winning move
now for white yeah work takes bishop and
then we do the knight and again it's the
same thing so didn't we pull it off
we have to spend a little time analyzing
the position before we decide what to do
white to play and win but we have to
take into account the fact that black
threatens Queen to h1 checkmate where
the Queen's protected by the knight on
f2 now once again we do have a possible
check with the knight on e5 to f7 and if
the King comes over we had that same
smothered mate with the knight to h6
double check King back Queen to GA or a
takes Knight f7 that's going to be our
saving grace the Queen diagonal is
blocked by that work though yeah we got
to stop the mate and you're right we got
to get rid of that stupid rook we can
stop the checkmate by attacking the
Queen and that's the right idea so the
main line is Queen takes rook and then
we do oh this is interesting we don't
start with the knight check because the
answer is rook takes Queen takes
enhances checkmate this is the move
that's really hard to see if you're
looking at it over the board you give up
the Queen now rook takes you get you're
smothering me right King takes now the
other night that was
around comes in forces the King back we
do the check and then the work comes in
and finishes him off checkmate
so that was pretty pretty tricky so this
is a win for black and you can see that
it would be look at this pitiful this
pitiful work here never never let that
happen to you and your chess games and
never let that your opponent's Bishop
wedge your key on g1 like that that's
just pitiful okay all black has to do is
figure out a way to break through I
believe that black was a famous American
chess champion he wasn't world champion
but he won numerous he was like US
Champion for 20 years or 25 years his
name was Frank Marshall you know they
made a chess club at net in New York
City that was there for a long time
named the Marshall chess club Frank had
a lot of rich friends he was from New
York and they set him up with the Chess
Club and that allowed him to pursue his
chest career because they they paid his
living expenses and and his train
expenses but anyway Frank was known to
be one of the greatest combinative
players of the day he was right up there
with the top players in the world what
held him back and he didn't make world
champion was he was a little he wasn't
as good in positional chess as the world
champion Lasker and capablanca the cuban
and ala came but he was edmond xt rose
in the top ten for many years so anyway
he's black here now obviously what you
want to do you want to get one of the
rooks either here guarded it is guarded
by the bishop though but if
this rook could come here that would be
checkmate right or if a worker could
come here and here that would be
checkmate of course
this square is guarded by the pawn in
the bishop so as they gonna work you
might work here that Bishop guards the
square that bishops not really a problem
is it
this rook is attacking that bishop we
can wipe that Bishop out and bring the
rook up or I'm not sure the exact order
but that's the general idea okay it's
blacks move let's see what Marshall does
Oh Marshall has a completely different
idea I told you he was good at tactics
so he plays he gives up the rook and he
threatens the bishop on c3 and the pawn
on f3 and if pawn takes rook he's got it
figured out he swings to the work here
he gets a discovered check he swings
over here and he picks up the rook in
the bishop and he's at least a bishop
ahead so it would go what would it go
something like this here here and here
and he's a whole workup so that's his
basic idea pretty darn good that's the
hard move to see how many people would
think of putting their Rick where a pawn
could take it if you're thinking about
it in your mind's eye you might just get
right over it because it doesn't make
any sense at all but you admit that the
Rick could come over in effect that pawn
on f2 is pinned because of the strong
move work to g2 so you have to look at
every possible move you don't want to
jump to conclusions I can't go my rook
to e3 because he just takes it see
that's jumping to a control
however the computer said that marshals
win was only one way to win there's
another way to win remember I told you
that one word could take out the bishop
so we could start this way and then
swing our rook up here and it turns out
that rook to g6 wins bishop to d2 and we
get a checkmate this is actually a
little faster than Marshall Marshall had
to work hard with an ending he was only
a rook up but I guess that wasn't
working too hard but this would have
been a checkmate so Marshall does get
the next he he made the prettier move
now we saw what happens with pawn takes
rook the computer says a little better
is moving the bishop up here and then
Marshall would take the pawn the bishop
would come down here the rook would come
back here Bishop would take the rook
then we get the g6
and we get our checkmate on move five
whereas if you had done it this way you
get your checkmate on move for but who's
picky I would be happy with the check
made either way okay let's go into our
next example this one is another win by
black I've actually gone through this
example when I was going through before
this book I was doing tactics by the
book by Siebert tarish the game of chess
was written about the same time and this
example was in that it turns out black
to play and win this is a famous game by
America's only other world champion
besides Bobby Fischer's they must Paul
Morphy
he was 20 years old before the Civil War
he was he was studied to be a lawyer he
was too young to practice law had to
wait till he was 21 his hobby was chest
he won the first United States
Championship the preceding year or
earlier in the year in New York City he
did so while the European chess masters
invited him to travel to Europe and play
the best players in France Germany and
England and because he couldn't start
his law practice he went on over there
and he played all the best masters and
he wiped them all out now he did lose a
few games here and there some in the
book they said well he was kind of
seasick he had to go by by sea and it
took like a month or something and
apparently it upset his he didn't have
sea legs he was a landlubber from New
Orleans so anyway he lost he would
typically lose the first couple games
against his opponent or maybe a draw
here and there and then he would
understand how his opponent play chess
and then he would win almost all the
other games after that so this is a
famous game from the first u.s.
championship he's playing another
grandmaster named Louis Paulson Louis
Paulson had come to America from Germany
there's a Paulson defense that still
played today in the Sicilian defense
it's named after this Louis Paulsen
Louis Paulson was no slouch
he could play 15 blindfold games against
opponents at this time and Paul Morphy
could do the same so they were pretty
evenly matched the difference was Paul
Morphy would make his decisions really
fast and Louis Paulsen would actually
sit there and ponder his moves for a
half hour to an hour this is before they
clocks they said when morphe was playing
Paulson some of the games might last
eight hours they said at times it looked
like more if he had tears in his hi as
he was waiting for Paulson to make a
move and then morphe which with this
move out and have to sit there for
another 45 minutes
but anyway anyway this is a beautiful
attacking combination by black what just
jump into it it's quite complicated but
lets me point out what's wrong with
whites position see how his queen is on
the Queen side and it's blocked by the
black Bishop and pawns and can't come
help defend the King side the black the
white rook on 8th a 2 is blocked by his
pawns
he hasn't developed his bishop on c1 the
only thing defending the King side is
the white bishop in the white work on f1
now the Queen does protect the rook but
that's only one diagonal it's not
sufficient and notice that all black's
pieces are aiming toward the king side
the two rooks at some point the rook
could come down to the e1 Square
protected by the other work take out
that rook on f1 and then the bishop can
come once that work on e6 is out of the
way the bishop can come to h3 and join
an attack on the Kings side so black is
all set up for a spectacular attack and
he starts off with the Queen takes
Bishop it's fairly difficult to see
exactly how he's going to win but we can
see that he gets a strong attack now the
G files opened up and look how
convenient it is that blacks work is on
the six so he can slide in front of his
pawns and attack the white king forcing
the King in the corner then the bishop
drops down now he's threatening to win
Bishop down check
and Bishop takes pawn that's actually a
checkmate threatened so White has to
move the rook on f1 somewhere the best
he can't go to g1 cuz the rook takes and
the other where it comes to e1 and
that's a checkmate or the Queen comes
back yeah and then the rook takes and
that's the checkmate
so he has to go to d1 now we get drop in
our Bishop so we're going to have some
fun with the White King force it over to
f1 now let's not forget this Bishop is
very strongly attacking this pawn here
don't forget that Bishop the but the
best move to win for black is to play
rook to the second threatening Rick
takes F pawn check and then the King
would have to go over to G 1 but that
opens up the bishop diagonally see that
so we can move the rook back to g2 and
then the bishop is on that G 1 square
and we go rook to G 1 is checkmate if
the White King goes to H 1 it's a double
check that when to work moves to G 1
it's a check by the rook and the bishop
on f3 and don't forget the rich
protected by the bishop so there's no
escape score that's a checkmate and if
the King goes to back to f1 we have work
to g1 checkmate because there's nothing
to take the rook ok so he doesn't really
have a move and now we see what I was
talking about the prettiest one is he
goes well if he goes here it's just here
and the same thing happens if he goes
over here because we get the double
check and he can't do rook takes rook
because the bishop
check-in him and he can't do queen takes
bishop because the wreck is checking him
so it's double check with me so that was
Paul Morphy he was pretty good Bobby
Fischer said Bob Murphy was extremely
good and that if Paul Morphy lived in
the day that Fischer lived in and had
access to all the theory and opening
books he would be J world contender even
then okay now we go back to a win by
white this is much simpler than the ones
we've been looking at so I'm gonna leave
it up to the audience to figure this one
out white to play and win
excellent an idea that bishops pinned
and can't take the Queen now we threaten
either Bishop takes or what we threaten
Queen takes would be checkmate there's
only one move for black what is it he
has to protect the bishop the only piece
that can protect it with is the rook now
this is a little harder you saw the key
move what what do you think is the
follow-up you put guys have been
sacrificing pieces all night keep it up
yeah but it takes Queen takes oh look
the Queen was defending two squares
remember it was defending d8 from the
white queen check and it was defending
f2 that's an overworked Queen so you
divert the Queen now we get our check he
has to interpose and we get our
checkmate anyway that'll do it for
tonight thanks for coming
[Music]